thank you
very much i'm very glad to be here
so i'll talk about abstractions uh for
multi-material uh 3d printing
you probably have seen that
multi-material that the 3d printing is
really
everywhere you you pretty much see and
and for example lots of different
magazines uh books
uh lots of stories in the media
but it's really interesting to look what
3d printing is used for
these days uh business analysts of
course will have a very sick you know
look at this market and
come up with many different categories
but if you look closer
you can group this in roughly three
different parts uh
one part the blue part is what we
traditionally think is the 3d printing
which is basically prototyping
used for presentations for research for
education
but there are these two very big
components that are rapidly growing
one of them is the use for manufacturing
so for example for using
molds casts or tooling parts for
manufacturing
and then there is this green part this
is uh
fabrication of the real functional parts
that actually are used as products so
this green part over there that's
roughly quarter
hasn't been there roughly 10 years ago
so it's very very interesting and this
is
on the top of that that this is really
growing at a very very large
rate i would like to give you a few
examples
of of three of current uses of 3d
printing so for example aston martin
has been looking into rapid pro
prototyping of of models of of their
vehicles and they built it from
composing different parts built
using 3d printers and these these models
have been used for example in the movies
uh
for example latest james james bond
movies
gvg aviation is really interested in uh
3d printing especially metal printing so
to give you an example this is a fuel
injection inject
this is a fury fuel injection nozzle
that traditionally
has been built using 18 different parts
and now
we can 3d print this part directly in
this one part and it's much more durable
and much lighter and this is not just
building a single component
ge is planning to build thousands or
tens of thousands of these components
nike is also pushing the boundaries of
3d printing for example
this is a real product they are marking
marketing this uh
football cleats with specially printed
plates
and the special structure of this of
this cleat can be only
3d printed and it gives you supposedly
very very high performance
hobbies makers and prosumers they are
really embracing
this this whole train trend so for
example they are
using it to scan 3d print different
figurines
but they also trying to build real
functional parts for example this is a
real
tape measure that has been produced
using low cost machines
and this is similarly 3d calipers again
pre-printed
using fdm 3d printers
my group at mit is uh pushing the
boundaries of 3d printing and
the trend that we are and the subjects
that we typically look at
is multi-material 3d printing
multi-material 3d printing is nothing
more than than than print 3d printing
but
printing with not just one material but
with many materials
so i would like to show you an example
so for example if i would like to print
this this piano i'm going to
discretize it in a small volume elements
and then for each of these volume
elements i have a choice
i can pick not just one material but
from a palette of different
materials there are a number of
different
3d multi-material 3d printers on the
market these days
both 3d systems and stratasys have
serious lines of these printers
just to summarize summarize the current
state of the art this hardware is
extremely expensive the underlying
materials that people use
are also extremely expensive the
material library is very
relatively small these printers can use
a two to three materials simultaneously
so not more than two and three
the software is in a pretty miserable
state very very limited software tools
there are really no material design
tools and everything
as a system is very very hard to use
so i would like to tell you about our
approach to solving some of these
problems
so let me first talk about the hardware
so our insight that we that we use we do
build 3d printers
we but we use computer vision to assist
building the hardware so using this we
can build hardware that's very high
resolution 30 microns or better
relatively low cost because we can use
relatively
simple components of the shelf
components uh
and and use computation to fix some of
the problems
we can print with multiple materials up
to 10 materials
the whole structure the whole systems is
extensible and we basically we can bring
in
additional three of both three we can
both
predict we can both bring new
parts and we can also add components to
the printer
and we can also integrate uh prints
with auxiliary components so this is a
hardware prototype
roughly from one year half ago
standard positioning system in xyz
coupled with ingredient printing and
very modular
trays that actually i where you can
actually attach different sub components
together
this is a smaller refined version of
this prototype from from last year and
we are working
on a completely new version this time
i would like to show you some of the
some sub components for example computer
vision
uh using computer vision you can
calibrate the system
extremely well the way you do it you
first put a calibration pattern
on the tray the system automatically
scans this
and it can compute the calibration of
the platform
with respect to the positioning system
you can also print with the nozzles
of the printer and you can calibrate the
positions of the droplets
of these nozzles and this can be either
using a user assisted way or computer or
completely automatically so basically
you get
a complete correspondence between where
you inject
or where the system is actually firing
the the nozzles
yes you do your calibration prior to
making a
parts run or do you do it concurrently
with making the part
so this is a very simple uh this is a
very simple
uh steps that can be done at pretty much
any time we typically
we typically do it first but i would
like to talk also about the closed
uh feedback loop so this is another very
interesting feature here uh
so we can actually use a system let me
go back we can use we actually have a
very high precision
scanning system that allows us to
estimate
uh the depth of all of all the parts at
at the micron resolution so this is used
as a
closed feedback loop for the whole
system so what does this give us
well you can actually do much better
printing with this
so uh basically if you like let's say
you would like to print something that's
very very flat
right you are going to print a number of
layers you are going to scan
the surface and then basically if there
are any imprecisions here
uh this is the surface depth map that's
something that's supposed to be flat
before
the before applying the corrective
layers
and if if there are any imprecisions you
are going to apply additional corrective
layers and then you are going to get
a depth map that that's within the
resolution
of the printer so using this system you
can actually have
obtained much higher precision using
using this corrective printing this 3d
assist
this three scanning system also allows
you to three scan
auxiliary components in c2 so what
what it allows you to do is to combine
3d prints with auxiliary parts you can
simply place
a three part over there and you can
actually print either on the top
of that part with with accurately
aligned 3d model so this is an
example of hybrid printing so what can
we do
with this type of system well for
example we can print
a different optical components we can
print micro lens arrays with for example
with
specially applied baffle we can even
print on the top of the surfaces
or screens directly with correct
alignment
we can print different metamaterial
structures for example
combining different elastic and rigid
materials and
and for example in this case building a
surface of building a material that's
that has negative concentration
basically
if you are trying to stretch it the
material is going to expand
we can print textured objects to objects
different types of fabric structures
with different again with combining
different materials
maybe with different colors functionally
graded
materials for example a material where
you change
elasticity from something that's very
rigid to something that's very elastic
so in general we have a way of expanding
the range
of 3d printing by combining all of these
technologies
i would like to focus more on software
in the stock so so let's look at that
so if you look at current industrial use
of multi-material 3d printers
you will see that we currently print
although there are capabilities of 3d
printing with multiple materials
with users typically pick one material
per given part so the main question is
here so why
why why one material per part and i
think
uh probably the the most important uh
constraint comes
from the designers themselves designers
still think in terms of designing
parts in terms of designing using cut
systems and
only specifying one material per part so
we
really have to overcome the sort of
thinking this limitation
that that that we can design with only
only a single material per part and
there are of course
more concrete uh problems well there are
really there's a really lack of design
tools there are really no good design
tools for this tax
tasks and as you will see there's really
a lack of scalable
architecture that would handle the data
size
that that multi-material 3d printing
provides
so our group have been working on two
different
ways of improving software for
multi-material 3d printing
and i think it's really good to to to
look at
both of them so the first of first of
these methods is direct specification
what do i mean by direct specification
let's say
i would like to 3d print a piano if i
would like to directly specify it i
would i'm just going to say
that the top of the piano is made from
this particular type of wood
the strings are made from this type of
copper the keys are made from this type
of plastic so that's
direct specification functional
specification
works slightly different i'm going to
specify the piano in the
in terms of its function for example i'm
going to say
that when i that the top of the piano is
glossy with that particular gloss level
and if i hit the given key on the piano
with the given force i'm going to get a
particular
sound from from the whole structure so
that's functional specification
let's talk about direct specifications
and challenges
okay so whenever you want to pretty
print
structures like this you immediately
realize that you have really problem
with data
if you are printing at 600 dots per inch
then you have giga voxel per inch cubed
or tera voxel of data per foot cubed
well and so that's the first one and
then there are lots of interesting ones
for example you have building continuous
gradation
between materials at very fine scale
it's extremely challenging
and that's also it's very difficult to
decouple materials
from underlying geometry and finally you
have real problems with
with building being independent of the
particle
printer and its native resolution
so what we have developed is openfab
openfab is programmable and scalable
fabrication pipeline openfab is inspired
by
rendering pipelines and similar to these
pipelines
for example as renderman or gpu
it has fixed stages and programmable
stages
it allows you to do procedural surface
definitions and
material compositions within the object
it provides you
with resolution independence and it also
handles the data sizes using a streaming
architecture so let's
first talk about the programming model
for this architecture
so similar to the rendering pipelines uh
it it it has both the the
it has the following stages so of course
you specify the input
you have a number of fixed function
status
you have two uh you have two
programmable
stages these programmable stages can
access different resources and finally
your output you also generate the output
in the form of 3d multi-material 3d
print how does this work let me show you
this on a very simple example let's
build this teddy bear
so the input are going to be boundary
representation the shape
we're also going to specify phablets
phablets are
subroutines that little programs that
specify both the surface detail
and material composition within the
object and of course we specify external
resources for example textures on our
materials
so the first step here is going to be
tessellation we are going to
figure out how we are going to
tessellate this in this mode
to micro polygons that are at the
resolute resolution of the printer
and then we execute the first stage of
this pipeline
in this case we are going to we are
going to execute the surface stage
of the phablet in this case we are going
to apply
a purling noise to distort the surface
geometry
this can potentially have very uh has
can have
many uses for example if you like to
create a model with some specific for
example
friction coefficients you could apply
this kind of micro structures to do that
if you would like to have some special
appearance you could do something like
this as well next we enter the
the voxelization stage so this means
that we are going to
to take this highly tessellated display
surface and we are going to voxelize it
and then we enter the second stage of
our phablet
and this is the volume stage this is
probably the most interesting part
of the whole pipeline so in this case we
are going to execute this
this surface stage of the tablet for
each voxel
the fabric takes x y z position of the
voxel
and it returns the material composition
of the given of the given voxel so as
you can see this is a continuous
material composition
3d printers cannot really put continuous
material compositions at a given
point they can typically only do one
material in a given
small volume element so that's why we
are we also have a dithering stage that
takes this continuous
distribution and applies something like
floyd steinberg
error diffusion to actually compute uh
the the discrete
assignment and finally we have the
output
i would like to talk about openfl this
is our
uh dsl for specif for specifying these
phablets
as you can see we have one tablet
per object it has two entry points
surface stage
and volume stage i would like to show it
on a very very simple example
building layered composites is a very
important
feature here so in this case we can
build a multi-material composite in a
very simple way
the tablet in this case takes a voxel
center and it has access to things like
distance function this is a sign
distance
function to the surface and using this
simple
if statement you can just assign
materials based on this distance
function
to to the surface we also built a
corresponding
architecture that's that's highly
optimized and and can
can execute the whole the whole
the whole process uh we had two three
guiding principles
well first uh we would like to have very
fast startup time
so this allows us to start the print
immediately whenever
we submit the job we also have streaming
architecture so we are going
to divide our uh our bottle
into slabs and slabs are going to be
memory limited so this is
they are going to have hold a few slices
and then we are going to process these
slices
from the bottom upwards and this
naturally handles the fixed memory that
we have
in our system so all of these things
give you a scale very scalable
architecture this architecture roughly
looks like this the first part here
allows you to uh to compute pre-compute
the different acceleration based
data acceleration data structures such
that
such that things like sign distance
functions can be
computed very efficiently and then we
have this loop that
performs everything for each slab it
finds the objects with
within a given slab executes the whole
pipeline
and emits uh the the end leaders the the
the the voxels that are sent directly to
the 3d printer
i would like to show you what we can do
with this type of pipeline let's
have a look at some of the results so
first
it allows you to do material decoupling
what it means that i can specify one
external surface but a number of
different
phablets and as you can see i can i can
change the way
the uh in this case these rhino models
look by by assigning
the material by by changing the material
composition
within the volume of of each of the
rhinos
it also naturally allows you to decouple
the geometry
uh from the phablet and in this case i
can for example specify this
foam structure and i can apply this to
this
teddy bear and i can also keep it
re-use it for later if i would like to
print let's say a stanford bunny
i can apply uh this phablet
to this to start stanford bunny
we can do uh procedural surfaces
with the surface tablets
in this case we specify as input only
the
slab of material and then
the shape of these lenslet elements are
completely
determined by the displacements from the
base surface so you can pretty much
uh specify the surface
analytically and then the printer
automatically is going to
compute the the the desired shape
according to some analytical formula
you can of course do procedural volumes
in this case you can
create this marble-like structures with
perlin
paralleling noise volumetric textures
this allows you to of course do
something more interesting uh
you can for example use these procedural
volumes to
build very custom fiber optics so in
this case
we are going to uh to have one sheet of
the material
that's completely planar and then by
changing the
refractive index within the volume we
can specify how the slide is going to
bend
and how it's going to be re-emitted on
the other
side what's what's really interesting
about is that it allows you to build
something like
this place with arbitrary shapes and the
way you do it
you take a standard 2d display you build
your
your custom volumetric display and print
this sort of custom volumetric
fibers and then you can connect the
display on one side
and and and have a very nice
display with with unusual shape
we can start building also other types
of functional objects so for example
using uh using uh the system we can
design
you can we can design only external
shell of using card we can we can import
this and the rest
all the internal structures are
completely specified
using our volumetric phablet
representations
so for example the handles the the whole
foam structures within the
within within the uh within the uh the
the
the ping pong paddle and then all of the
little uh
dimples on the surface of course you can
build more and more complex
uh functional parts in this case this is
a
a complete ski uh that has been 3d
printing not the bindings
uh and in this case we can design a skew
with that has both
pretty realistic appearance properties
and
mechanical properties so these are the
results
these are the types of results that
openfab can provide
i would like to move to a
functional specification next so as you
have as
i have described before functional
specific specification
is where we specify function of the
object
and then the system is supposed to
figure out
how uh how to translate these functional
specifications
to actually something that you can 3d
print so we
call this process of going from
uh specification instructions to
something that you can print directly as
spec
to fab translation so
how would the spec to fab translation
work in the case of our
imaginary piano so in this case
i can do the following things i can
start
with some material assignment to the
piano
to different parts of the piano i can
use some simulation where i can simulate
how the structure is going to sound and
i can compare this
to our functional goal in this case this
of course
doesn't work so i have to pick another
set of materials
uh simulate it again and and compare
this to the goal
well if you apply this to 3d printing
multi especially
material 3d printing this really doesn't
work basically that
if you just are going to try oh it's
really not possible
to try all possible combinations over
there so this this really
doesn't work so so this naive
process this naive spec to fab
translation process has to be changed in
some ways
and and and we changed it in the
following ways
so so instead of working in the space of
original
uh voxels and their material assignments
we are going to work the space of
reduced parameters
and we replace this random material of
assignments with some
of course some optimization algorithms
so i would like to briefly tell you what
this uh
what this reduced parameters mean so if
you
uh would if you would like to uh design
a given shape right so so if you if you
look at the
the the set of shapes that are spanned
by all possible voxel assignments you
know they are going to
reside in some high dimensional space
if you look at the space of of of pianos
that can be described
using for example multi-material 3d
printing that satisfies our
goals this is going to be some set like
this
this the the goal of our
reducers uh or is is to to to be able to
build
these uh low dimensional reduced spaces
design spaces
such that the such that this design
space is not going to be
so much different between the the this
this high dimensional design space for
all possible piano designs
so we need tools for designing these
reduced spaces we have looked at
many algorithms in in computer graphics
and in material science in mechanical
engineering in robotics
and we sort of saw that these
spec-to-fab translation processes
share this type of structure and
when we look closer each of these
sub-components
have a some number of different types of
building blocks and
and for simulation for compile for this
compile go comparisons
optimization people use pretty much very
similar blocks
people don't really look that much at
how how to
how to reduce the space of possible
parameters
and what are the building components for
those
okay so so we have come up uh with
a set of data structures that are used
to solve these problems
so in particular we have a a
a reducer tree uh data structure that
allows you to describe
the set of uh that that allows you to
describe the space the your design space
and we also encapsulate the whole
optimization and simulation process
within
a tuner network so first let's start
with the reducer tree
reducer 3 is a fabrication specific
decomposition of the design space that's
hierarchical
it provides us with the parameter
reduction and it subdivides the space
in some non overlapping subdivision
this reducer tree has basically internal
nodes
internal nodes provide spatial partition
of the space and the leaf nodes leaf
nodes provide
specific material assignments when
looking uh
at the previous literature we pretty
much looked at
we we found that it's possible to
describe these reducer
trees with a very small number of
different nodes
so for example one type of model that we
typically see
is a stratum node this this node takes
arbitrary geometry and
decomposes it into the outer shell and
the inner
core we can subdivide this this geometry
we're using for islam columns
using voxel lower resolution voxel grids
using some planes
using some spline surface
the leaf nodes can provide material
assignment and
one of these material assignments can be
also avoid material
they can be also parameterized material
structures so for example if i have a
foam
data foam like material i can
change but i can have i have i can have
a low parameter model
that describes this material for example
the sizes of or
each of these of all each of these holes
can be
determined using some parameter
so let me give you an example how
reducer tree works for a very simple
example
for for for an example of of textured
objects
so in this case we are going to take an
input geometry and we are going to
subdivide using the stratum node
then we are going to take an outer shell
and we are going to
uh subdivide using the column node
and then we are going to assign one
material node to the internal surface
of of of the of this node of the stratum
node
and this is going to be just one bulk
material and then
finally we are going to pick layered
materials for each
of the nodes in the in the columns
so this provides you provides you in
general with a fairly
compact representation of the design
space
that has much that has much fewer
parameters
compared to the original number of
voxels
so what are the parameters that we have
here for example stratum
has the thickness uh columns have
width height and of course the
corresponding material nodes have
the variables they're the corresponding
material ids
and as you can see of course we can
change all of those
okay so now we have our parameterization
of the design space and now we would
like to actually
to optimize it to tune it to a given
specific task
and for this we are going to use tuners
tuners provide
an abstraction that uh encapsulate all
of the simulation and optimization
process within one
building block and they provide an
abstract interface between
the the essentially the tuner between
the the
nodes within the reducer tree and
and simulation optimization so we can
attach these tuners to
any of these of the nodes in the tree
and then this
node is the tuner node is is
responsible for tuning material
parameters within this
within a given within the material node
we can also attach the tuners
to internal nodes with the tree in this
case the
the tuner is responsible for optimizing
the whole the whole material assignment
and the whole material parameters within
the whole subtree
so how does this work basically tuner
collects the tunable parameters
in this case with height and material
ids
updates the parameter values uh and and
and
and and it can actually iterate within
that within a given loop
we can optimize each node separately so
we can attach an
a different number of tuners to two
different nodes and we can
we can also uh specify the schedule of
for these tuners we can also build the
whole tuner networks that actually can
share
information between the tuners
so we allow communications between these
tuners
i would like to show you what kind of
things you can do within this network
within the system so first you can do
things that are fairly straightforward
for example you can build something uh
that works fairly well for for texture
so this is a fairly
uh simple uh tree and the tuner network
in this case the input is the geometry
and the texture
and the output is at model that mimics
this this model and the texture
once you design this you can of course
uh
reuse all of this so if you specify a
different model with different texture
the whole thing is going to work again
we show that you can reuse a lot of
these structures if you
move to more complex properties for
example in this case if you would like
to
build a functional specification and
specs
to fab translation for subsurface
scattering
you will reuse most of the corresponding
tree you will change
the tuners and we are going you will be
able to optimize this
of course you will be able to also apply
it to different types of
geometries as well
this structures also allow you to
analyze
different types of uh spec to fab
translation processes
so in this case we are going to we can
actually compare different algorithms
that people have proposed so in this
case
this is a structure uh this is a gold
these are so called gold-based acoustics
these are very complex lens structures
that are 3d printed
in this case you have a light passing
through the through the to the lens and
it can actually form a complex image so
one particular algorithm
uses this type of tuner network and
reducer tree
and we can compare this to another
algorithm that
achieves very similar goal with
different
reducer tree and the tuner network so
it's very useful to compare
between different types of algorithms
what is very nice about this this type
of strat of of this type of structure
is that allows you to combine different
processes together so for example if i
would like to be able to optimize
both deformation properties and texture
we can build
a corresponding tuner and the
corresponding
reducer 3 data structures
okay i would like to say how all these
components fit together so first you
have
hardware and materials and the direct
specification
layer has to communicate directly
with of course with with the underlying
3d printing hardware
and and functional specification should
really reside
on the top of that so the output of the
functional specifications should fit in
as inputs
to the direct specification is that
all well of course not we of
what's really important is building
being able to build
applications and interactive design
tools at the top
of of of these abstraction models i
would like to show you a
few examples of the things that we have
done in the space
so here i'm showing a complete uh
multi-material
cut system where you import 3d
surface shell and in this case we are
going to
build a twill this is a combination of
tire and the wheel
and in this case i'm going to build a
shader
network style composition of different
operators that are going to compose
very complex structures this is of
course very much a speed up but
but this we are showing on the top uh uh
here as well that the course the whole
network of operators that are
applied this is very analogous to the
shader trees that are used for for
rendering where basically you have a
small number of of basic building blocks
basic
components that can be combined in some
creative ways
and design some complex geometric
structures
and of course you have to provide things
like different types of
inspection tools you have to be able to
provide
interactive preview tools and so on so
these all of these things have to work
at at
different levels of detail because in
the end the small this model has
has potentially has a terror box of data
so you have to be able to evaluate
things these at interactive rates
in order to provide interactive preview
for the users
the second project that i would like to
show in the space is
computational design of mechanical
characters
so people have been building these types
of uh mechanical
characters uh uh and and robots for
uh for a while the problem with this is
that of course it is
very very hard it's it's it's really
restricted to
only a small number of expert users and
we with these type of methods
we would like to be able to bring it to
to non-experts
so this is a sample of of a system that
we have
designed in this case we already have we
assume as input
a character that can be 3d printed and
now we
would like to be able to uh to animate
this character
as similar to virtual characters so in
order to handle this task
a user to going to specify a given bone
uh within uh for this character and
the user is going to to draw a
corresponding motion curve
how a system is going to bring
a corresponding mechanism that's going
to satisfy
this motion and we can repeat doing this
for different
types of joints and in the end we can
actually obtain
mechanisms with a very complex
structures that can be directly 3d
printed
and assembled together
so how do we do this well there's no
free lunch here
and you have to start somewhere we have
to start in our case we start with a
library of mechanisms
so there are a number of mechanisms that
actually can produce a
huge variety of motions
what's really interesting about is that
we make these uh
mechanisms parameterized so even if you
take this very simple five bar linkage
you will see
that it spans a very large space of
different motion trajectories
if we are going to start changing this
the parameters here you will see that
the corresponding
motions that this simple mechanism
provides can be fairly
uh fairly varied
and again this is a very very simple
structure
okay so we have the database of these
parameterized components
and the next step in our case is going
to be
to a sparse sampling of of all of these
of all of the parameters and com
pre-computing different parameterized
motions
and then when the user uh performs uh
the drawing of the curve the our system
is going to bring the corresponding
mechanism that has the closest matching
motion
trajectory to to the desired one and
it's going to
do a small refinement uh using some
continuous optimization
and this happens to work actually fairly
very well
there are a few bells and whistles that
we also provide so for example if you
would like to
change different uh
phase between the motions of different
legs in this case you can do this with a
very simple interface and just
changing the face of the connecting of
the two gears
we can also provide custom velocity
profiles and this is used
using uh using uh non-circular gears and
specifying
the using with user interface how this
how the velocities should should change
as a function of time
once you specify the motions for all of
these uh
uh parts of the character
it's often very useful to drive this
with only a single motor
so in this case we also provide a
relatively simple
user interface that tells that just
allows you to specify
how many different parts should go in
between and the system automatically
connects these parts together using this
system we have
designed a number of different
mechanisms this is just a sample of
those
and we have fabricated actually most of
them
i would like to show you some of the
examples in detail so this is a
pushing man that many of you probably
have seen
and if you would like to give it to a
design of this to a casual user it will
be extremely hard
using our system this can be done within
a few hours
of of of even for non-expert
designer including 3d printing and
assembly
this example shows that we can also
build mechanisms
with uh internal driving uh so in this
case it's just nothing more than
specifying the constraints for the
system
where the mechanisms should lie
in general the current system only
allows you to specify planar motions
but it's fairly easy to combine plane
motions in different planes to to
achieve motions
in 3d
i would like to show you some
limitations so this is
all limited to the kinematic design and
of course we are very interesting to uh
this
to extending this to physics such that
you know this this little character
actually can really work
and not fall down
okay uh the last project i would like to
uh uh present is is really extending
this to
to to more and more complex things so so
how can we do this i mean
how can we make a leap from from these
little characters to something like a
car
well it's it's of course uh
there's i i would like to say there's no
no free lunch here
and our approach in this case is to
use a data driven design so we are going
to start with a database
of fabricable and parameterized designs
that are designed by by expert designers
and we also are going to provide tools
that they are going to
fuse provide some mashup of these
different designs
a composition tool that's going to fuse
them together to produce
more and interesting designs potential
designs that can satisfy
some desired goals so let's
let's look at the database we have i
have been working with a group of of
talented mechanical
uh uh electrical engineers that that
that build
a sample database in this case and
immediately when you start building
even something very simple you observe
that you don't have uh that these are
really not computer graphics modes you
have suddenly
uh thousands of different parts uh even
for relatively
small designs so this is very different
than
traditional graphics model that that
that that we see
what's really interesting about our
designs
that they all of them can be
manufactured so all of the components
point directly to some online catalog
that tells you
how you can actually purchase this
component and obtain it so this they
they point to real physical things
and our designs are also parameterized
so since we can already
design many of those designs we have to
sort of expand the database in this case
similar to all these geared mechanics
all of these of these
linkages we also make each of these
designs completely parametric
and as you can see these designs can
have both continuous parameters
and discrete parameters so as i extend
this part
the number of the connectors here change
okay let's talk about our modeling or
composition tool
so it looks roughly like this you can
start very simply by taking one of the
original designs and you can the user
can play with different parameters
changing the the where where each of the
components can be located
what's really even more interesting is
the composition how can we
create a composition of different parts
from different from different uh from
different objects that were originally
designed
so in this case we provide tools that
allow you to snap
the components and resize them
automatically
we can handle articulated models so for
example if we
bring these doors doors to this cabinet
it knows automatically that should
resize
it looks for cabinets that are similar
and sort of figures this out
automatically using the data
if we bring this this for example this
drawer
it looks for the corresponding
connecting mechanisms that should be
copied
from from similar structures
this shows that if you try to compute
for example
a wooden tabletop on the top of this of
this table
the corresponding connectors are going
to be very very different
and again the system allows you to use
the data that's already stored to figure
this out
we also provide some physics simulation
here
this is extremely important we have done
we really haven't done
a lot but we we uh we obviously think
that this is something that that needs
to happen
more and more so in this case it's just
a simple
way of evaluating whether a given design
is stable or not
and so then of course this provides an
interactive feedback to the user
this shows an interactive modeling
session and i think this is something
that
a casual non-expert user could
potentially uh
uh be able to to do so in this case the
user just springs and drags
corresponding
components from the from a database out
the system automatically resizes those
and finally when the design is ready
everything can be ordered
and the whole design is completely
manufactured manufacturable
what's really nice about this approach
is that it's really all about data
and extracting information from the data
so the same system that can be used for
building for
for example furniture can be pretty much
used to build
go-karts and we have managed to build
some go-carts and even to
to drive them in the building it was
winter so so we had to drive in the
building
no breakdown okay so this is this is a
cs
audience i i think mostly cs audience i
don't think i have to convince you that
that abstraction is really crucial if
you would like to be able to
scale the complexity of uh
of 3d printed or fabricated
objects so it's extremely important and
there's lots of
interesting problems that encompass
copyright graphics simulation geometry
hci data driven methods machine learning
optimization so
lots of very interesting stuff that are
very uh interdisciplinary
even within the computer science putting
this talk in the
bigger context i really think that that
being able
to have these output devices that are
inexpensive
that are very powerful it's going to
really bring us
closer uh to bring bridge the gap
between
virtual and rio and i really think this
is
very powerful and i see a really greater
role for computer science here it's
really going to
hold as a glue to act that that
that keeps everything together and as i
said
we are going to see more and more
interactions between computer science
and
other disciplines things disciplines
like
bioengineering architecture
material science or mechanical
engineering
i would like to acknowledge my
collaborators
students and the funding agencies
and that i would like to conclude the
talk with that
thank you
open for questions
seems to me the voxel is awfully small
as a
unit to be working with
is there something equivalent to raster
graphics for this space
for vector graphics vector graphics
so i would like to say that yes and and
i think it
almost comes more from from uh
from a different fabrication method so
what i have
talked about is a very good abstraction
for
for printers that that three printers
that print using rasters
there is a class of printers such as fdm
printers
for example makerbot style printers that
print using
vectors basically you're having a small
filament that
that moves and prints as vectors so i
think there is very interest there are
very interesting questions
about how can we build similar
abstractions
for vector-based 3d printers and how
maybe how can we have abstractions that
mix
both raster based and vector
vector-based
3d printers in addition to
3d printing maybe uh analogy of vector
graphics would be
you know say if you're if you're having
a material such as wood and we cut out a
particular piece and i think you had
some examples of this
i think there is a way to combine uh
these two approaches
it's just yes and no and i want to say
that that that
that you will probably need very
different abstractions for manufacturing
wooden patterns for example if you
want to manufacture something might of
of the food it's
more of a process because you are going
to for example first cut the wood
that you are going to apply some coating
layer and so on so
so i think the underlying process might
not be intentionally
local it's going to be a fairly global
system so in my opinion
that some of the low-level abstractions
probably should change in this case
did you have to build your library of
mechanisms yourself
or are there things available uh out
there somewhere there are definitely
things available
and i think this is going to be very
interesting uh uh
area of future work or research how can
we re reuse
cad designs so i think this is a very
very interesting area
for future work yes
there are lots of difficulties with that
reuse in my opinion
uh we have we have
how to make everything compatible it's
very difficult to make these designs
compatible if you would like to fuse
designs are made by two different
peoples
uh it might be a problem that's why
before we
uh we did the project we almost had to
had a
training for for uh for all of the
mechanical engineers that were designing
this sort of to
agree on some set of rules at least at
high level
you know how they should design yes
well sort of equivalent to the idea of
putting together
a formal specification for the threads
on screws
and yeah the sizes of screws and the
lengths of the shafts
something like that yes but i think more
of a high level i would say
worthwhile to kind a formal way to
define functionality
so that we don't just store a category
store and function if we want to
yes then you know you can adopt it for
something else
yes that would be very nice i agree
your talk is obviously on algorithms and
representations and languages and
issues and user interfaces and all that
i'm having hard
relating that to any kind of a real
world type manufacturing machine you
seem to be printing plastic
and metal and glass and wood
and paint surfaces and i'm not sure
where all your
what machines exist currently that can
be doing output and those kinds of
materials simultaneously
i think i mean at the low level right
you can
build definitely components from from
all of these uh
you can so so you can definitely build
components in all of these materials
right uh you can i think what's really
interesting about this that
for low-level tools you probably need
all of these interesting
uh abstractions to to to make the apps
to make the fabrication processes
scalable
at the high level i think you can use
these data driven
composition tools for a variety of
different methods so you can
you know use things that are 3d printed
things that are not 3d printed
so this is i don't think that i don't
sort of see
this as a as a big problem as you
actually build
uh uh things from components and there's
a
large category of objects that actually
are com
built from components you know you're
talking about like doing both material
materials at a per voxel level with
checkers
yes of course yes and the idea is that
would all be
printed at once growing up from a layer
yeah
has any machine ever been able to do
that with last for instance
what what what printers now exist that
can do more than one material at a time
something interesting
there are a number of industrial
machines both 3d systems and stratuses
have these machines
as i said the problem with i think the
main problem with with this
with these types of machines is that
these are closed architectures
and it's very difficult for external
people to experiment with those with
this with these architectures for
example if you would like to develop
your own material
it's pretty much impossible so that's
why this prompts us
to build research platforms like this so
we can experiment with the whole
but it pipeline seems like the issue is
material science
absolutely problems not representation
it's like being able to fabricate wood
for instance seems like a very difficult
task absolutely
there are absolutely lots of interesting
uh
material science questions over there
and there are a lot of people the
the material science people who are
working on this product
lenses and for lenses to be useful they
have to have
you know turquoise smoothness on the
order of wavelengths
depends on the type of application yes
but yes
but you can potentially obtain this with
special manufacturing processes even
within the context of additive
manufacturing that that might be
impossible someday there are already you
know a number of companies
that are working specifically on that
one of the interesting applications uh
it's
thought to be successful is the
creation or printing of
uh organs yes for uh medical
purposes yes how does this how does that
how do you distinguish that from the
making of rhinoceros uh dolls for your
desk
i think i think there are definitely
lots of interesting
questions over there and
depends what what types over there there
are at least two different ways in which
you can
do tissue engineering one of them is
printing scaffolds
so whenever you're printing scaffolds
this is very similar to this
right if you're printing cells directly
this is this is definitely much more
challenging
lots of interesting issues on the on the
on the on the biology side so and
people are really actively trying to
figure figure this out lots of people
working working on
on this i think on the on the simulation
side was probably very interesting to
look also at the time
domain how because whenever you're
printing something
that's that's life you would like to see
how is it going to change
over the period of the time so i think
looking uh also you would have to also
look at the
the time aspect over there as well i saw
i saw
a announcement of a device that used
uh growing uh bacterial
cellulose as the primary uh
mechanism for building the scaffolding
is that
something which is moving into the
mainstream do you think
there are definitely some startups
working this technology you know
what's going to pan out of this you know
that's interesting
i wish them success
i thought i thought it was interesting
that they would be trying it
but they are definitely they are trying
it's very very yes
a cell is an incredibly complicated
thing to
actually print a cell we're not going to
do that anytime real soon right
right so print a virus nothing wrong
people are growing cells and printing
heterogeneous structures from the
cells that have been grown already but
you got to grow the cells you can't
produce
right yes yes right i think we could
probably do a nematode
even a cell of a nematode give good luck
you've talked about this in terms of new
manufacturing which is effectively
printing how about old manufacturing you
know
wire edm edm bills
drive the same same sort of issues
exist there and does the same thing fit
into the framework
uh some yes but i mean you are talking
about uh
printing uh designing electronics and um
yes well absolutely i mean i think there
is a slight difference in terms of
subtractive methods versus additive
methods i think the
the abstraction has to be somewhat
different whenever you work
with with subtractive because uh
working with multi-layer structures over
there is a little bit more
so so so i think manufacturing process
pose some specific limitations that
i think should your abstraction should
handle
but the subtractive processes
do they do the their i mean they have
beams
that taper but is there much more
complexity in the
sort of variation like your meta
material i can imagine
i can imagine making that out of both
steel by
varying the number of pinholes i put for
uh per area yes and make you know
but you can't that that's very
complicated to think about unless you're
taking the same approach with dithering
and yes i think that
there are definitely i think i would say
it's harder because i think there are
more i think there are more limitations
coming from from
uh from from from the uh from the
fabrication process
a combination of of additive and
subtractive
is even harder because you can also
imagine you know growing something then
sort of
shaving parts of it growing more and so
on so that i think the algorithmic
complexity of these processes is even
more more difficult
i don't think people in cs have even
tried to to attack any of these problems
but this is definitely something that
that we are capable of doing
yes you're a tool builder what tools do
you use to build your tools
like what programming languages what
kind of interactivity
systems you're using um
i mean we are trying of course to reuse
a lot of the existing open source
tools um uh
we're using c c plus c plus plus mainly
when if you just make a block of plastic
how dense is it relative to the raw
material
there's a got air pockets in it so
printing
air pockets is incredibly hard because
in order to print an air pocket within
the material
you have to uh
you you have to introduce some support
structure
at the voxel layer or the little air
pockets between the
blobs of plastic that you put down that
depends on the manufacturing process
typically in the process that we use we
do not have any air pockets
in other types of uh for example in fdm
based process you definitely have these
air pockets that you can introduce
so this depends on the manufacturing
are the are the process really solidly
attached to each other
yes in our case yes yes yes yes
absolutely
so if i had a prototyping lab and i
printed out
a fantastic machine and i then wanted to
put it
into mass production uh what
is around that would help do that um i
assume that mass production
mechanisms today yes uh are quite
different than printing mechanisms
uh if i want high volumes
like in injection molding foreign
um vacuum forming even is yes
it's different than uh yes so so i think
the the interesting part over there is
you inherently limited
i i would say with a with a with
something that's that's
fairly uniform material and i think it's
so this is and i
and we are specifically trying to
address the multi-material
nature of 3d printing and having this
very high uh uh spatial varia
being able to have materials with very
high spatial variation
and i think having that that this
capabilities
and people have shown that of course it
gives
lots of interesting
materials with with very unusual
material properties that cannot be
obtained using
traditional methods
not to harp on reality um
relating this to something that might be
built
with multiple materials yes you
you seem to answer a few questions
saying basically some assembly would be
required you know you
fabricate the parts and then put them
together but if you're talking about
combining a dozen materials at the voxel
level yes
that has to be done as a process an
integrated circuit you don't
glue the transistors together
so what in your lab what do you have
running that can be printed with more
than two mega
two materials at the same time in a
single integrated structure
what do you actually have things working
in your lab that can print multiple
materials
what materials uh
well basically we are mostly working
with polymers most of
with we are mostly working for polymers
but polymers that exhibit different
types of struct
properties polymers that have different
uh
mechanical properties optical properties
conductive properties that's the extent
want to go back to where john john was
just a moment ago you said
john that you know semiconductors you
know
they don't put pieces together to try to
build a
structure um i i know some
semiconductors that are in fact done
that way
and the question i guess that that comes
back to is
what's the scale here how big is the box
how small can it be
well depends on the on the on the on the
on the technology i think
if you work with existing things and you
would like to you know do things very
very fast for example you know
hp had announcements some time ago so
that
the ingredient-based technology that's
probably going to
have the limits of around you know some
very small
low microns i would say i don't i think
it's probably going to be very difficult
to go
sub microns it's probably going to be 10
low tens of microns in terms of
resolution so this gives you
roughly you know hundreds of dots per
inch so
yeah it's yeah yeah
so so there's a thousand standards it's
often big but
yeah exactly small by 1950s well i know
this is
now we're now in the uh 21st century
things are a lot bigger than they used
to be or smaller depending upon your
perspective
so can
can you see the technology extended to
to dealing with really really small
things so now
of course i mean there are obviously
people working on on nano based
printing technologies typically they are
much slower so
it will take it takes a while to to to
to do something but you know maybe this
could they can be
this is not something that i personally
work but there are definitely
lots of people working on in that area
we've seen some people who were talking
about building
uh critters for buildings
yes of course yes where basically the
the uh the element that is being
producing extruded material is a
pressurized concrete yes absolutely
and that strikes me as being
sort of practical because it's really
conceptually easy to deal with yeah
i i you know i haven't seen anything
i've seen i've seen some structures uh
build this way
i have i don't think i've seen a real
house definitely doing work on that
actually sulfur-based concrete mars
nasa well there was a conference here on
campus
absolutely but i still haven't seen a
real
big 3d printed structure
photographs of yourself of something
that looks like a small
house but nothing like a real functional
building sports stadiums i think they're
being done
oh okay so
they're always what's the names
i think this brings really an
interesting uh
point here is that uh most of of of
printers the sizes of the objects for
most of the country printers
is limited to the of course they have to
be smaller than the size of the printer
right
if i think what's really interesting so
building 3d printers
yes but small printers and big things
exactly
yes exactly but that moves you
immediately in the realm of robotics i
would say
you definitely you know you are sort of
i think so
lots of time you do for the show yes you
are solving lots of robotics problems in
this case
so are there are there facilities
currently in place
where people organizations
provide 3d printing
facilities for building prototypes
if i wanted to go build a prototype of
something
are there places i could go to to do it
because the printer is actually
a small part of the
market's need for things you
only presumably you could use it for
short period of time
absolutely not don't use it for
production because that's going to be
too costly
as i said some sometimes you sometimes
know sometimes you are going to build a
functional prototype
sometimes as for example g is showing
you can use some of the parts
to actually as real functional parts
that you put in real products
so so uh i think what's really
interesting that
that that i think being able to have
access to all these technologies of and
being
you know being able uh to put a product
that is composed maybe from a part of
three printed
particular part that that's for example
it's cnc meal and putting them together
i think this is very interesting i think
there are lots of
i think efforts even educational efforts
and demonic
campuses to establish the so-called
maker spaces
where students are learning how to use
all of these technologies and how
combined
all of these technologies to build real
functional products and it's very
exciting i think
i think most of the universities are
trying to have efforts in this space
cool anybody else
he said you've got to present an
equation relating the minimum feature
size to the
volume
because you can't do a football stadium
one micro dot at a time
i see one of my colleagues is actually
trying to do exactly this he's in
mechanical engineering department john
hart at mit
and he's trying to actually you know try
to to draw
yes to to have to actually derive
right you're building this yeah if
you've got the vision there's no reason
you can't use lots of little robots well
sure there's definitely some pokemon
positions there's so many cameras on the
robots
and if hp is selling the ink it's an
awfully expensive
just as a rule of thumb i know that
about uh about five years ago
no matter what machine you bought or
anything you had about four thousand
dots
per unit length at the machine actually
what's kind of the rule of thumb now
i could i'm not sure if i understand
because like
about we have about 4096
pixels or voxels you could put across a
device that was 3d printing something
whether it was a 4-inch device or an
8-inch device or a
yes you know 2-foot device no matter
what it was it was about
so again if it uses i think if it's
typically it's limited by the
technologies that are driven
by the by printing industry so we you
know people are
using a lot of the same components that
traditional 2d printing
companies use so that's why we are
pretty much stuck in whatever
2d printers can do these days i mean the
limitations i think are inherently
similar and sort of economies of scale i
think
are very very similar printers are
incredibly
uh fine scale you know pico meters
yes yes but
for 3d printing you're putting out
bigger resolutions and you know the
resolutions uh dots per inch or dots per
meter yeah the question is what's the
number of dots per unit length that's
kind of
state-of-the-art today so i i think i
think
there are definitely consumer-based
printers and there are commercial
printers
commercial printers i in general have
much wider
printheads right they can print with
more nozzles that they have
they can actually output more so so i
think
no no i don't know i think large scale i
look at 72-inch epsons
yeah and they have the same resolution
that a
uh dust plotter epson has yes resolution
yes
the resolution is the same resolution
just
yes the the width or the printhead is
larger yes resolution
is you know so much per inch right right
of course
and what do you see the uh state of the
art today as opposed to
five years ago when i said it was a
4096. i i don't think this is really
changing that much because i think
i don't think people need more i mean
what is the state of the art how many
dots per inch can you do in your lab
like 600 dots per inch pretty much i
mean this is maybe
people fake you know maybe 1200 or
something like this so you can
you know just like everybody else yes
what do you expect to be the most
important commercial applications
of the commercial 3d printers say in the
next five years
the most important commercial
application are
i think we'll probably see
being able to uh to do functional parts
very very well uh essentially better
and it's an especially functional
prototype so i think you will be
probably
be able to to to design a prototype that
sort of
looks much closer to the original
product so i think this is going to be
very interesting because
it will allow people to iterate on
designs very very quickly
my non-informed opinion is that when i
look on
ways that economically it'll be jewelry
for women
i think it's rocket engines yes like you
know but
there are lots of things that will be
very difficult to do like a shaver for
example i know
yes yes but i think i think people i
think it's going to be interesting how
how to extend the boundary of what what
can be done
uh today and so be able to print a
chamber actually yeah
so i think this is going to be really
very interesting and i think it's going
to be
happening so basically we'll be
extending the range of things that we
can
we can do so there what about
intellectual property here
um copying parts is pretty easy
yes uh there are parts you can't make
with a
uh with a 3d printer not because you
can't be done but because it's illegal
yes parts for certain kinds of guns
they the design files are available
online of course
and
you know we've seen the the uh
dilution of intellectual property rights
for
written materials uh
sort of going away uh although
there's still some pushback what happens
here this is
this is uh presumably going to allow
anybody to make one off of anything
yes and i i i think there are lots of
very interesting
question in the space right you know how
how can we incentivize designers to
actually produce
very interesting high quality models
right this is real work right how how
can we do this
you know how do we have things that open
source
do we have a netflix model where
basically you have access to a
big repository and then you can download
and print you know
we have a monthly subscription do you
you know print you know uh i do we have
we just put your that's not that
microphone
right dcma the robot comes up and takes
your stuff
i think lots of money the printer makes
it gun and shoots you
and then it shoots itself
you